المترجم: Imed Boumaraf
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
كان هذا سؤالاً كنت قد طرحته على أصدقائي
في أحد المرات ونحن نتناقش
وكانت إجابتهم كالمتوقع.
دعنا من العلم ووجع الرأس يا أمجد،
فلتونا انتهينا من المدرسة!
فأخبرتهم: لماذا العلم ممتع ومهم.
فنظروا إلي بنظرة مفادها
إن لم تصمت سنذهب ونتركك
ومن ثم عادوا إلى نقاشهم حول
لاعبي الكرة وآخر إنتقالاتهم.
فأعدت لاحقا فتح موضوع العلم مجددا
ولكن بطريقة مختلفة هذه المرة
أمسكت أحدهم وكان متعصب قليلا
وطلبت منه أن يأخذ نفساً
فقال لي: ماذا ؟ قلت له مجدداً خذ نفساً
وبمجرد أن استنشق هذا الهواء، بدأت الحديث
قلت له يا صديقي لو حسبنا
بالسعة الهوائية للرئة
(أي كم يمكن للرئة أن تحمل من هواء)
والحجم المولي للغاز،
سنجد أنك في هذه اللحظة
استنشقت مالا يقل عن
3*10^23 من جزيئات الغاز
أي 3 خلفها 23 صفر
فقال لي: "حسنا والمعنى؟"
فقلت له: "هذا معناه أن هذه الجزيئات
قد كانت موزعة على كل الكرة الأرضية تقريبا"
وبمجرد أن أخبرته أن هناك احتمال بأن
واحدة من هذه الجزيئات
قد كانت في رئة مرادونا وهو يفعل
في حركة الزقزاق
أصبح كل انتباه الفتى معي وترك
باقي الأصدقاء وبدأ يسأل كيف ولماذا
مجرد أن خلقت لديه هذا الفضول بدأت أتعمق له
في أسئلة علمية أكثر وبدأ يسمع مني
ورجعت به حتى لموضوع
أهمية العلم الذي لم يتقبله في البداية.
الشيء الذي اكتشفته لحظتها
هو أن الناس لا تكره العلم
إنما تكره الطريقة التي يتم بها توصيل العلم
لأن العلم في أساسه مبني على الفضول
الذي هو جزء من الطبيعة البشرية
كلنا عندما كنا أطفال كنا نجرب ونستكشف
ونسأل في أسئلة مثل لماذا السماء زرقاء
ولماذا القمر يتبعنا.
كنا فضوليين جدا بمثل هذه الأسئلة.
لذا المشكلة ليست في العلم بذاته،
أنه ممل أو معقد، لا،
المشكلة في طريقة توصيلنا للعلم إلى الناس
في اعتقادي العلم مثل الموسيقى مهما كان حسن
التأليف من الممكن أن يكون مزعج
لو لم يتم عزفه بطريقة صحيحة
وبعزفه أقصد توصيله
وهذا ما أحاول فعله مؤخراً،
هذا الشغل الذي يستهلك جل وقتي مؤخراً
توصيل العلوم، عبر التبسيط
واللعب على وتر الفضول.
ولكن هذا لم يكن حالي دائما،
لسنوات كنت شغوفًا بالعلم
ولكن غير قادر على توصيله لأحد.
بالضبط مثل الشغوف بالموسيقى
ولكن غير قادر على عزفها.
هذا الفيسبوك ذكرني بتلك الأيام قبل 5 سنوات
ومن وقتها وأنا أعمل على تطوير نفسي
أتذكر في بداية شغفي بالعلم أني
كنت أسرق في هاتف أبي الان 81
وأفتح الويكيبديا أحفظ المقالات العلمية
كصفحات محفوظة وفي كل مرة أقرأ مقالا
في وضع عدم الاتصال بالإنترنت.
أتذكر كذلك أني كنت أشاهد العديد
من الوثائقيات العلمية، وكلما عرفت معلومة
جديدة أشاركها مع الناس،
أتذكر في مرة عندما عرفت حقيقة أنه عندما
نرى النجوم في الليل فنحن في الواقع نرى
ماضي هذه النجوم وليس وضعها الحالي
لانها بعيدة لدرجة أن ضوءها يحتاج لفترة
كي يصلنا، لم أترك أحد ولم أخبره،
بكل حماس كنت أحكي ذلك.
ولكن كان الأمر مؤلمًا نوعا ما أنك لا تجد
رد فعل بنفس الحماس من الطرف الآخر
لذا كنت مستغرباً لماذا لا يوجد
اهتمام بالعلم والبحث العلمي
وليس لمجرد أنه شغفي فقط
ولكن لأني كنت مدرك أنه ضرورة
لحل المشاكل التي تواجهنا في المجتمع
مثل مشكلة الكهرباء التي نعاني منها يوميا
لو أننا كنا مهتمين بعلم الطاقات المتجددة
كان من الممكن أن لا يكون وضعنا كهذا!
العلم لديه أقوى منهجية لحل المشاكل
نظرة سريعة حولك وستجد أن كل صغيرة وكبيرة
في حياتنا من الإضاءة إلى الميكرفون
إلى مكيف الهواء
كلها اختراعات جاء بها العلماء لحل مشكلة
معينة، فلماذا لا نعطيه اهتماماً أكثر!؟
كان هذا الموضوع يشغل
بالي منذ أن كنت صغيراً
وكنت أحاول أن أُقنع نفسي بأن مجرد اهتمامي
بدراستي هو أكثر شيء يمكنني فعله
ولكن اتضح لاحقا أن بإمكاني فعل المزيد
في أحد المرات خلال دراستي الإعدادية في حصة
العلوم وكان الدرس عن الشحنات الكهربائية
وكانت المعلمة تشرح كيف أن الشحنات
المتشابهة تتنافر والشحنات المختلفة تتجاذب
فسألتها لماذا؟
فقالت لي لأنها متشابهة ولأنها مختلفة
فلم أقتنع وكنت من النوع الكثير السؤال
فقالت لي ما رأيك أن تأخذه كواجب منزلي
فعدت للمنزل، قلت حسنا
وقمت بفتح الانترنت، كتبت السؤال،
شحنات مختلفة تتجاذب، لماذا؟
لم أجد أي نتيجة لما أريده
وليس مع السؤال هذا فقط،
حاولت البحث عن العديد من الأسئلة
التي تراودني ولم أجد أي نتيجة مما أريده.
وأعتقد أني لست الوحيد
الذي واجهته هذه المشكلة
تأتي لتبحث عن معلومات عن النجوم،
لتجد نفسك في منتديات الكورة،
والنجم ميسي يتألق
يعني نتائج البحث عن نجوم الفن والكورة
كانت أكثر من النتائج عن النجوم الحقيقية.
بعد فترة اكتشفت أن هذه مشكلة كبيرة بذاتها،
واسمها "مشكلة المحتوى العربي على الانترنت"
حسب احصائية للإتحاد الدولي
للاتصالات قام بها سنة 2012
3% فقط
المحتوى الكامل بكل أنواعه وتفاصيله
فما بالك بالمحتوى العلمي إذن؟
ربما النتائج تكون ضئيلة
لدرجة تكاد تكون معدومة
فعندها أدركت أن المشكلة
الحقيقية "مشكلة المحتوى العربي"
يعني 400 مليون عدد المتحدثين باللغة
العربية مقارنة بالـ 3% لا شيء
لا ننتج أي شيء!
حتى وإن وجدت مواضيع علمية
فغالبا تكون مكررة ومن دون مصادر.
ولكن مع بداية دخولي على عالم
الفيسبوك مع سنة 2012-2013
اكتشفت عدد من المبادرات بدأت
تعمل بالفعل على حل هذه المشكلة
فكانت كدفعة نوعا ما بالنسة لي، وقلت لنفسي
لماذا لا أساهم في أن أكون جزءا
من حل مشكلة المحتوى العربي
وقلت ربما هذا هو الشيء الذي
يمكنني فعله غير اهتمامي بدراستي
ومن هنا كانت بداية
النادي الليبي للعلوم سنة 2014
مبادرة علمية هدفها تبسيط العلوم، ونشر
الثقافة العلمية وكذلك إثراء المحتوى العربي
ولكن كبداية أي مشروع وجدت نفسي
أمام الكثير من الصعوبات
من غير الانترنت والكهرباء اللذان يقطعان،
لأن عملنا الكتروني وكان يعتمد عليهما
كانت هناك صعوبات أخرى مثل
الترجمة والتصميم والتدقيق وهكذا
في البداية بدأت لوحدي،
وحاولت ترجمة بعض المعلومات
مع أن لغتي كانت بسيطة، ولكن عملت على رفع
مستوى لغتي الإنجليزية، للوصول للهدف
الذي وضعته لنفسي،
كذلك حاولت تعلم الفوتوشب لعمل صور
توضيحية تجذب الناس لمجال العلوم
ولكن بعد ذلك وجدت أنه لوحدي لن أستطيع
أن أكون مساهما في حل المشكلة بشكل كبير
ولذا لابد من تكوين فريق،
ولكن كيف يمكنني تكوين فريق؟
انضميت لمجموعة عربية مشابهة
وتعلمت منهم الادارة نوعا ما
عملت معهم كمصمم، أي بعد أن تعلمت الفوتوشب
بشكل جيد انضممت لهم كمصمم،
وتعلمت منهم الإدارة نوعا ما
كيف أن لهم قوانين لتنظيم أنفسهم.
وكذلك قرأت بضعة كتب عن ادارة المنظمات.
ولكن هناك مشكلة لازالت عائق بيني
وبين تكوين الفريق وقد كانت العمر
في وقتها كان عمري حوالي 16 سنة
وكنت متخوف أنه إذا عرف أحدهم عمري،
فربما لن يشعر بأن المشروع جدي،
أو لا ينضم، ولن يكون هناك ناتج عندها
فماذا أفعل، ماذا أفعل؟
وجدت طريقة
قمت بانشاء حساب فيسبوك آخر قمت بعمل اخفاء
للعمر ووضعت صورة اينشتاين كصورة شخصية
مجرد أن طبقت هذه الفكرة، بدأ الكثير
بالانضمام الينا، ووصل عدد الفريق لحوالي
30 متطوع
حتى أن بعضهم أصبح يناديني
أستاذ أمجد وسيد أمجد
بهذا استمريت قرابة السنة والنصف في هذا
الوضع المتخفي،
نترجم وننتج في مقالات
إلى أن شعرت أن كل أساسات المشروع في مكانها
وكل شيء في مكانه، كشفت عن شخصيتي الحقيقية
طبعا كان رد فعل الفريق الذي معي،
ضحكوا وأخذوها بروح رياضية
ولكن سامحوني بعد ذلك لأنهم اقتنعوا
أنه كان شيئاً ضرورياً لنجاح المشروع
اليوم النادي الليبي للعلوم لديه أكثر
من 2000 مادة على فيسبوك
في مختلف مجالات العلوم من الفيزياء
والكيمياء والأحياء والطب والهندسة،
اليوم لدينا موقع الكتروني هو الأول من نوعه
في ليبيا، مهتم ومختص بالعلوم، وبموثوقية،
دائما بالدليل وبالمصدر.
(تصفيق)
ويوجد فيه أكثر من 500 مقال مترجم،
كذلك تمكنا من أن نتعاون مع مبادرات علمية
أخرى ناشطة كانت على المجال الالكتروني
وتمكنا معهم ليس على نقل المعلومة فقط،
إنما أيضا نقلنا طريقة التفكير العلمية،
طريقة التفكير النقدي، بموضوعية
وبالدليل والمصدر
وهذا أنا متأكد أنها كلما انتشرت على مدى
أوسع، كلما تغيير حالنا للأفضل
تمكنا كذلك العام الماضي بالتعاون مع جمعية
رؤية لهواة الفلك وعدد من المنظمات
من أن نأسس لأول مهرجان علمي يقام في ليبيا،
والذي كان مهرجان الثريا 2016
(تصفيق)
اليوم لا أشعر بأني متضايق مثل ذي قبل
لأنني ساهمت في أن يصبح هناك
اهتمام بالعلوم في وطننا
ساهمت أنه يكون هناك المجتمع
الذي كنت أطمح لرؤيته
عندما أشارك المعلومة
وأحصل على نفس رد الفعل
اليوم تعرفت على مئات الناس الذي يملكون
نفس الشغف والإيمان بقضية العلم
وتمكنت مؤخرا بأن أحظى بمحادثة مع أحد
عازفي سيمفونية العلم الكبار
الذين كنت أشاهدهم على الوثائقيات
وهي عالمة الفيزياء الفلكية
في وكالة ناسا د.ميشيل ثالر
حيث قمت بسؤالها عن النجوم الثنائية
وسعدت جداً بردها المفصل الذي بدأ بجملة
"هذا سؤال عظيم"
(تصفيق)
لكن مع هذا كله من الضروري فعل
المزيد لدعم مسيرة العلم في بلادنا
أنا شخصيا لا أريد إمضاء كل حياتي أمارس
العلم عن طريق الانترنت وخلف الشاشات
أريد رؤية العلم واقع على الأرض
أريد أن أرى مراكز بحثية
وأن تكون ليبيا من الدول
التي تنافس على التقدم العلمي
أريد أن أرى مهرجانات علمية وقبات فلكية
ومجلات علمية مثلها مثل مجلات الرياضة والفن
لماذا لا تكون موجودة في كل مكان؟
وأنا متأكد أن هذا الشيء قابل للتطبيق لو
عملنا معا على إتاحة سيمفونية العلم للجميع
ورأينا لأي نقص فيها على أنه فرصة لعازف
آخر يعلوا بالنغم أكثر وأكثر.
عندها، حتى السؤال الذي سألته في البداية:
" ماذا يعني لك العلم" لن نضطر لسؤاله
لأن الجميع سيكون مدركاً
بأن العلم شغف وجمال
بأن العلم قوة وتقدم
بأن العلم طريقة تفكير وخير محور للتغيير.
شكراً، شكرأ جزيلاً